I'm torn today I'm torn I'm I'm elated
but I'm also a little bit
upset why am I
elated Ryan Gosling has received a Best
Supporting Actor nomination at the
Oscars which nobody watches and nobody
watches 90% of the movies that are even
nominated at the Oscars this year but we
all saw
barbie and some people hated Barbie like
my colleague down in boa Ron because he
didn't understand the movie and some of
us who did understand the movie
loved Barbie because it's a conservative
Masterpiece and the the most clearly
anti-feminist movie since grea gerwig's
first movie called ladybird I didn't see
little women that might count
too so Ryan
Gosling for all of his kenergy that was
teeming out of him maybe he had some of
those little nicotine pouches I don't
know he gets the nomination Margo Robbie
who did a great job in the movie gets
snubbed for best
actress worse still
Greta
Gerwig one of my favorite current
directors and I I watch very few movies
so she you know maybe she'll be the only
director I'll watch for a year or one of
three but G Gerwig arguably the most
conservative and Christian director
working in Hollywood today at the
Hollywood level and in that depraved
place gamor by the Sea some of us call
it she got snubbed as well for best
director I think that's outrageous some
people think I'm joking or trolling
because they think that Barbie is really
woke or whatever it's not it's really
not I actually don't see how one can
watch
Barbie paying even a modum of attention
and come away thinking that that is a
left-wing movie it's not it's not even a
kids movie by the way some people said
I'm not going to watch Barbie because
it's a kids movie selling toys it's not
even a kids movie but but I see why some
are confused Barbie is a movie for
adults masquerading as a kids movie that
has a con conservative message
masquerading as a woke poic there are
all these lines in the movie about
feminism and the patriarchy and you know
and that that's all people hear but
they're not paying attention to the
context of those lines the lines are
ironic Barbie land which is this
feminist fantasy is a fantasy it's a bad
place there's something rotten and
broken about it and the protagonist
here's a spoiler alert chooses to leave
and go to the real world the world
supposedly dominated by men here's
another spoiler alert the movie opens
with girls being nice and playing with
their little dolls and loving their
little baby dolls and then Barbie comes
along the Barbie toy phenomenon and the
girls start killing their babies and
becoming feminists the whole thing is
presented as a this is a feminist
Revolution and it leads to women killing
their babies and then at the end of the
movie big spoiler
alert the protagonist chooses to leave
Barbie land specifically because she
wants to have a baby she has a a
conversation with the god character the
Ria Pearlman character who created her
and she has a vision of the future that
she wants and the vision is pretty much
just her being a mom and having kids and
so she leaves Barbie land and the the
final funny scene of the movie is she
she's waiting in a in a little reception
area in some non-descript office
building and you all think okay this is
Barbie leaving the fantasy world to go
get a job and go be the real Barbie you
know be the real feminist and she's not
she says I'm here to see my
gynecologist the even the very final
joke is no I'm not going to go be a
career woman no I'm not going to go be
this feminist icon I'm going to be a mom
so anyway I've got much more to say
about Barbie but it's just clearly
conservative I don't know any I
sometimes I will grant you I read a
little deeply into things and I I try to
admit it when I do this one I just think
you could
be you don't need to have read the
collected works of Edmund Burke to
recognize this has a conservative
message to it so what does it mean that
they got snubbed I think it actually
butresses my argument because it's a
conser it's very popular movie and it's
kind of conservative and maybe that's
why it got
snubbed it is at least funny I'm not
sure that that's the reason maybe there
were other internal politics in
Hollywood it is at least funny that the
Ken character is trying to advance the
patriarchy within the feminist Utopia of
Barbie land and uh Ken is the only one
who gets the nomination that's kenergy
patriarchy undefeated
but but that question is even grappled
with in the movie highly recommended
highly recommended that you go see that
movie right now go to genucell.com
letter y letter T here is a great New
Year's resolution you can keep whether
you have 3 minutes in the morning or 30
minutes keep your face wrinkle-free with
jell introducing Jen 90 the new instant
wrinkle treatment from gen youell gen 90
instantly reduces the appearance of
wrinkles anywhere you use it from around
your eyes forehead Crow feet or laugh
lines it starts working in seconds
genell says their gen 90 is two
generations better than any immediate
effects product and years ahead of the
skincare on the market I totally believe
this uh the owner of genus cell came
over here from Egypt cop a Christian
came over here for the American dream
and he focused on quality Above All Else
grew this company to be a total
Juggernaut and and the way he did it is
he gives you a really great deal knowing
that you are going to be a customer for
a very very long time best ingredients
out there right now our listeners will
not only get over 70% off Jus cell's
most popular package but also free
shipping Jus cell.com lettery letter T
secure your gen 90 product before they
sell out genucell.com
nsyt today speaking of return to
patriarchy there is a terrific Bill
coming out of o
Oklahoma a bill that would ban
pornography which is something that
pretty much everyone wants other than
the perverts and the weirdos everyone
wants this and everyone has wanted to
ban or severely curtail
pornography forever it's not a
republican thing it's not a Democrat
thing
forever obscenity pornography was banned
in America for most of our history in
most places and then even in the 90s
when the internet came out and and
lawmakers had to Grapple with this new
technological problem both parties came
together to regulate and severely limit
pornography they did it through two
pieces of legislation the communications
decency act which is where you get the
section 230 that protects big tech
companies in some ways from uh oversight
and in the child online protection act
both passed by Republicans Democrats
signed by Bill Clinton it was just some
Libs on the court who shot it down
and pretended that there was a First
Amendment right to weird hardcore porn
but most Americans forever have
recognize that there's no right to
watching perverts degrade women on
camera so that other perverts can
degrade themselves in a dark room it's
it's just it's degrading it's not
conducive to human flourishing and so
there's a lawmaker in Oklahoma a state
senator who would make watching porn a
felony and ban sexting among people who
are notri mared so some are saying okay
maybe the guy's gone a little far and
you know it's maybe it's a little
aggressive but he's starting a
negotiation here okay and his position
is far closer to the traditional
American view of these
things his position which is what is he
really saying he's saying hey discourage
people from being perverts and
discourage people from committing
adultery that has been the law in
America it's certainly been the cultural
norm in America and in every reasonable
country for all of
history his position is much closer to
the reasonable one than the position of
the liberals who say yeah go out cheat
on your wives have a thropple chop off
your body parts and be a pervert all the
time this state senator Dusty ders much
much closer to
reality how are we going to get this
across for those of us who recognize
that at least in principle this this law
is a good thing we're going to need to
make some new coalitions we're going to
lose some of the Libertarians some of
the Libertarians are going to support us
we're going to lose some of them we're
going to lose a lot of Democrats
especially these days some of the
Democrats are going to support us but
speaking of Barbie and confusion about
feminism and what feminism even
means conservatives should Ally with the
feminists here not all the feminists the
sex positive feminists are
lost but feminism used to be deeply
anti-p pornography sex negative feminism
was a major strain of feminism and they
opposed it because pornography exploits
and degrades women always all the time
and some of it is particularly degrading
and particularly violent
even the conservatives this is not just
some pie in the sky wouldn't it be nice
if we could work with the feminists we
did this on the issue the traditional
conservatives Al lost some Libertarians
on the issue but we allied with the
turfs the exclusionary radical feminists
and we've been immensely successful we
have gone a decent way not the whole way
we still have a lot of work to do but
we've gone a decent way toward uh
eradicating for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who Fallen pray to that confusion
we did that with a weird political
Coalition that included a group
traditionally considered on the left and
and feminist but they were on our side
on this issue same thing could happen
with porn and we should do it man what a
great clip that was now hold up ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael and N
YouTube channel we'll see you next time